ma fa ricetta arco rapporti più horror
ragazzi un attimo già uscendo roba di
qualità appena esce la faccenda che
posso fare tutto ma che per le prossime
taglio horror appena esco non li faccio
ad esempio detto che è uscito questo che
si chiama dei knights of the screw vedo
che già il menù non è male questo gioco
è realistico perché appena prenderò la
patente bene ragazzi cominciano a parti
subito così non ho capito niente di
quello che devo fare non ho capito
perché siamo finiti quasi gas for active
and show non credevo attivare gli assi
ma che cosa devo fare lo ammazzare solo
la gente o devo fare qualcosa in
particolare che è successo
devo centrarlo con la pista non ho
capito ma chi siete voi da dove siete
usciti ma cos'è uno non è vero aspetta
che mancati tanti sì uno a posto 2
non ho più colpi c'è una pala sea of tv
sporca brutta
c'è questo che corre addio oddio
nominato aia mi hanno fatto fuori
non ho capito cosa più giovani e delle
sky kraus a ma sto giocando online non
ho capito
ok allora vivevo di arrivare dove dov'è
che ce ne sono tanti poiché piano nello
spuntati dati perché sono e se ne spunta
tanti più facile a 1
in una sala occhio è mancato tantissimo
porco il demonio lo corri corri dai
carica
1234 questa la combo aiuto ma dai l'ho
colpito mar ho colpito prima io
ma andate a cagare che abbiamo messo
anche quest'anno invece la new entry per
questa di semplice chi chiede shot gun
ho attivato questo salve ma per chi si
chiama la notte degli spaventapasseri
qual è il problema perché sono
spaventapasseri tutti questi che si
muovono magari non lo so c'è il
confronto con lo più di zombie sono
niente ma laddove si è uscito porca
vacca no spedo ricarica un attimo un
cristo
ai ragazzi ai a qualcuno ha colpito la
10 ma non vale escono nei più dai punti
impossibili non si capisce niente sto
gioco pre bellissimo mi fa strano
ragazzi che ti sciotta non c'è poco
discettano come se niente fosse
chi per due vai carica queste più
risicati e fucile a pompa mi aiuta un
sacco però sono quasi morto caput
diciottesimo al mondo ci hanno giocato
in 19 tra i quali mihajlovic che una
volta giocava nell'inter avere stavolta
non malato ogni tanto ti da un'arma
diversa la meglio volare prima ragazzi
fidatevi porca la google obiettivo è
quello di raccogliere più un gas
possibile informare perché con questo
flare e infattibile sto troppo ok un
anno trovata io praticamente l'obiettivo
è quello di arrivare a tirare al massimo
giusto orca perfetto aiuto perfetto
regali o smontati tutti meraviglioso
come meraviglioso dove arrivare un altro
eccola qua ho attivato una trappola che
mi ha ammazzato sul professore un genio
cavi quella vacca quanto può essere
difficile gioco degenerata in tamil arma
recente questa è un'arma vera arma degna
vai ci penso io
dove la gente dato non solo 3 o cosa
quello ogni te cos'è
marca vecchia questa veramente forte
cioè non ho ben capito se effettivamente
man mano che vai avanti c'è gente più
forte di quello lì però credo di sì
madonna è veramente difficile
ve lo giuro raga non sto capendo una
sega c'è una scala la posso raggiungere
mi sono fatto malissimo mi sono ucciso
ok quindi non ho capito se l'obiettivo è
continuare a sparare alla gente o se
proprio devi fare qualcosa tipo
raccogliere le taniche non lo so
partire con la macchina di jason di
venerdì 13 non ho idea tuoi stessi
devo raccogliere il massimo delle
taniche forse quindi tutto un raccoglie
le taniche credo
procedi con 72 per cento però aspettare
ed altro con un secco in testa stanno si
spaventa passeri senza un motivo
va bene potreste farmi ma cosa che
succede ogni tanto che mi si sposta il
personaggio come se mi invitasse
qualcuno in faccia blauer defense però
fare il livello della madonna pressa
f.to presto va bene frey completa ha poi
pregare
ok maria primi grazie al conte meno che
da round wine sprechi e poi round one
grazie e maria non so cosa sia sul
rumore ma non mi piace per stanno
attaccando la madonna maria ti devo
difendere non lo sapevo e non lo sapevi
facciamo li facciamo non lo sapevo maria
ci penso io ho fatto fuori un fatto
fuori senza alcuni qua sono morto però
perfetto occhio maria ti sto difendendo
io difendere la madonna è comunque
ottimo
almeno lo capisco l'obiettivo quindi
l'obiettivo è resistere la maggior parte
del tempo
l'obiettivo non può essere ok occhio
occhio maria
avvertimi a meno che ti resto perfetto
non può stare a fare recuperare vita in
qualche modo sbagliato
benissimo non vedo la gente mi devo
girare ogni tre secondi perché non vedo
round and had the time for a prayer
andare a pregare maria arrivo prega
prima veloce che manca poco variate
questa questa questa per salire ok
perfetto non è male è quest'arma non è
male però il flare dall'alto è una
devastazione quindi player basta l'uomo
era scambiata volckler hanno perso il
suo gioco regali prego
sto giocando maori te
porca vacca se avesse avuto ste armi i
residenti vol
madonna molto corre quel quelli che
corrono velocissimo mi inquieta non sa
ancora che non so se è normale ha detto
ho visto impegnato il sacco
un nuovo maria occhio round and had the
time for a prayer matteo kay perfetto
trovato punto scende sono anche fatto
male cazzo dammi un arma della madonna
maria ti prego ti prego mi serve perché
sennò eccola o perfetto se non ho colpi
la nobile insomma è un cecchino è un
cecchino de cristo fermi tutti
e un check mano zuma ha sì un po zuma
ok ma secondo me sono sempre dei
downgrade del re il razzo era veramente
molto più forte di tutti il razzo era
l'arma suprema rega questo in confronto
fanno cagare assieme un call of duty che
faccio threesixty sulla madonna si è se
per caso dovessi vincere maria dami
l'arma decente per favore che questa fa
cagare madonna che jam schermi sono
cagato addosso che regga dipenderà
l'arma che ciò ma forse ho trovato il
modo che ho cercato ho passato gli
ultimi dieci punti a tentare di bloccare
il gioco e forse l'ho trovato forse non
ne sono sicuro però per farlo ho bisogno
di un attimo di culo ok di culo gioco
assisti mi ha già da quando di pigliano
ok maria un attimo non li pigliano
scendere ma più ok presa è però non vedo
bene a mercato perché avevo trovato il
modo giusto
abbiamo perso però peccato perché era il
modo giusto quella che quando mi
picchiavano era veramente una figata
adesso devo sopravvivere finché non mi
ammazzano e due parole però non lo so
non so come potrebbero mai fare visto
che sono completamente la sua quotidiana
l'obiettivo non è mariano obiettivo è
sopravvivere la maggior parte del tempo
quindi questo qua ago questo ho un po
battuto il record praticamente mi basta
sta fermo teoricamente a meno che non si
tratti di un bug non dovrebbero riuscire
a uccidermi bene che lo sapevo perché il
di barche sono proporzionali a quanto
costa un gioco ragazzo è un gioco costa
poco tranquilli
2 pieno pensare che ho passato per ben
dieci minuti a testa cerca starò bene
sono riuscito maestro proprio del glitch
dei giochi bello che se spari anche
senza ammirare il colpo va dritto ayane
ha fatto male questo prestito di culo
come fatto vabbè ma non finirà mai
l'ondata perché comunque mi hanno fatto
fuori maria mi teoricamente non va più
andate o sbaglio l'hack è male ma chi è
che mi fa danno chi è che mi fa danno ma
c'è qualcuno che mi sputa ma non ho mai
fa questi sputano e io che ne so quindi
ecco che le ha fatto male anche nei
livelli precedenti c'è uno che sputa che
ne sapevo io con questo resistendo un
sacco effettivamente sono molto bravo
skillato alimenti al mio obiettivo sono
diventati questi qua che sennò semi
piano sputano esso nella cacca
quindi via no mi ha buttato giù che
finale inaspettato ma buttato giù
fortissimo ragazzi possiamo batterli
tutti mi bastava avere un'arma diversa
però signori questo era the knights of
the scarecrow zoom dei knights of the
bug sul corrimano anche quello potrebbe
essere un titolo azzeccato per ora vi
sia piaciuto ricordatevi di difendere
tutti la madonna che ci vediamo come
sempre al prossimo video si chiede al
canale un bacio 66 animals ciao ragazzi
[Musica]